how're you guys doing today pretty good
how are you doing excellent I want to
start this interview off by saying
sincerely how much I loved the show I'm
this is one of these thrills for me
having you guys come in studio I just
want to say thank you it's really really
cool
and we're out that's all I got no so so
I watched the doc last night and as a
fan of the show I learned so much that I
didn't know and it was just it was just
so cool and I wanted to know what was
talked a little bit about the genesis of
the doc and how this whole thing came
together and how it took shape back in
2012 and I was at the convention in Las
Vegas I hadn't been to a convention in
13 years and I had got to see Avery
Brooks because I'm like these people who
had seen over the years I hadn't seen or
heard of Avery for a long time so I
wanted to see Avery and that's why I
went
we had a great reunion I was in a
terrific mood I was standing you know on
the floor of the convention and Dave's a
pone the co-director of this doc came up
to me and said I'm thinking of doing a
deep space 9 documentary and Bill
Shatner isn't going to do it because he
just did three documentaries on Star
Trek back to back to back he's not gonna
want to do another one how would you how
would you our bear-like to be Bill
Shatner and interview all the actors and
I thought I was in a good mood you know
I felt a real kinship again with the
show and without thinking I said yes and
then I said what what's it going to be
about and what's the point of view and
he said don't worry we'll find it as we
go along and we did find if he didn't
tell me would take four years just to
find what the hell the doc was about but
that's how it came about well one of the
things is that this was another one of
those successful IndieGoGo campaigns
that the fans really chipped in to make
this thing happen and that sort of adds
a little bit to AIDS it's fan you know
really for the fans but be you guys do
some cool stuff in the dock in terms of
showing ds9 and HD and especially
talking about what could happen in the
season 8 could you sort of four could
you sort of talk about those aspects of
the dock well I think it's Irish credit
that you know he always had the fans in
mind and I think you know and every time
I got a phone call from him he said you
know listen we got to do a little bit
more for the fans because they're
throwing more money in the bucket here
so you have to remember when we did the
IndieGoGo campaign we'd been doing the
dock for a number of years already it
was originally a one-hour documentary
that was it that I thought an hour how
tough could that be right an hour we
could do that quickly interview the the
family and we're done and even when we
did the writers room that was 2015 that
was two years before the Hindi go-go
campaign so we did the the writers room
when I still thought it was gonna be an
hour dock so how we were gonna fit it
all in don't ask me I wasn't thinking
that far ahead I didn't know what the
hell I was doing to be honest and then
Dave came to me in 2017 he had gone off
to do the Spock dock and I hadn't been
in contact with these guys for a while I
was off in Scotland doing that Lander
and he said listen we have to finish off
the dock we need some music ask or have
to hire a composer we have to do some
animation we're gonna ask for $150,000 I
said can we make that will the fans pay
that he said well I think so I said
don't tell me you think so I don't want
to ask and then not get you know it's
gonna make me feel horrible he goes oh
we have 30 days you know we should do it
we should we should make it in 30 days I
said okay Dave but you better not be
mistaken and then in 24 hours we made 29
hours we made 150 I think well I think
something that the IndieGoGo campaign
did that we weren't expecting was it
changed the framing of the documentary
we had gone into a thinking well it's
gonna be an hour film it's gonna be
stuff we've already filmed
but we we had no idea that the fans
would be so so adamant for something
more than that and we kind of thought
well it's a it's a cult following it's a
small group of fans they're they're
underground they don't really follow the
show anymore and we were blown away that
there were 10,000 people in a very short
amount of time that we you know we
barely publicized the campaign but they
came out and they said no we we
absolutely want to see this we want to
make sure you get through not just your
first funding goal but we want to see
Deep Space Nine and HD we want to see
Deep Space 9 animated we want to see
everybody back together so that forced
us to not just sort of settle for what
we had been talking about already but
actually make it into a feature-length
film and to do about 50 new interviews
and and that campaign allowed us to do
that and do everything that we wanted to
do with the film one of the things I
want to touch on and I have a lot of
questions about the show I swear we're
gonna get there but one of the things
that I've absolutely loved about the
documentary was thinking about what
could be the season 8 and I um before we
get into that the there's so many shows
that get sort of that come back if you
will because of the popularity and I'm
just wondering is there any possibility
at all that like and how does it work
with the legal with Paramount and stuff
of doing anything with these ideas that
you came up with four possible season
eight whether it be comic book animation
live-action is is it even possible what
number one I just want to make it clear
that that was not the intent yeah but it
was still awesome I get it and we wanted
it to be entertaining but at no point
did I expect or want anything to go
beyond that one day of getting the guys
back together and breaking an episode
you know I just wanted to see what that
would be like and I thought it would be
cool for the fans you know we already
have been asked you know back in the day
if we wanted to do a comic book graphic
novel and I said no III don't want this
to be to go anyplace else unless they
would put on you know a full season of
Deep Space 9 or do a feature I don't
want it to be a novel or a coloring book
or anything like that that was not the
intent we did one day
if we came in for a second day a lot of
what probably was that would change in
little ways like we did whenever we
broke a story on the show this was an
exercise to entertain the fans and to me
that that's good enough sure it really
worked and as far as the novelist's have
been pretty good I admit that I don't
read the novels but I've been told that
all of our characters have been expanded
on by the novelists that put out Deep
Space nine novels every month I think
with paramount books
I loved the practical sets that you guys
had and they looked so it's one of the
reasons why the show looked so
believable is it just looked like a real
place what would surprise people to
learn maybe about those sets if there's
anything you know any secrets you can
share they look massive but I think
people would still be surprised if they
walked on how elaborate they were and
how huge in the promenade and it was
easy especially after like 16 hours of
work to believe that you're looking at
the stars you know and to believe that
we're in a space station it was it was
really remarkable the sets were
beautiful I had worked on Deep Space
nine and other shows as we all have and
when you go on those sets the regular
sets are divided into little beehive
comb things and as no Nadja said when
you walked on a Deep Space nine it was
the promenade that it wasn't divided up
the distance from quarks bar to Oh toes
was always the same because it was
always it was that distance it wasn't
divided up I remember the first day that
I worked on the set I was gobsmacked at
the creation of it that that there it
was it was it was a world inside this
building yeah I didn't get down to the
set a lot of course was just so busy 26
episodes a year but when I did go down
to the set I noticed something really
odd I never quite being in
you know ops did not make me feel
comfortable
it was the Cardassian architecture I
guess it just it was not a welcome and
welcoming place ops
but quarks you know quarks was a bar and
I really believed it was a bar and if I
could get in there and kind of hang a
little bit even if they were shooting
not in quarks but on the promenade or
something and I was just that I said
watching I'd always try to kind of hang
out in quarks question it just made me
feel more comfortable it's really odd
one of the things about the show that I
still can't believe is nowadays doing 22
episodes of any show is next to
impossible no no I'm saying a normal
show 22 episodes you guys did seasons
two through seven I believe were 26
episodes apiece how the f did you pull
this off back then and how much when you
reach the episode 20 or 21 when you
ready to just like punch a wall you know
in terms of because all the make up
trying to do all this these guys had it
really the hardest it was Monteux how
they did it I did it for a couple of
shows being completely covered in rubber
and it it's you you have to talk at
least I did I had to talk myself through
the day not to panic I I don't I don't
know how you did seven years ago mine
mine was easier than ironmans because
Armen did all the episodes I just came
in and did my occasional turn as Garrick
and then left for a few weeks and my
skin would have time to heal we did it
because we were professionals and we
were expect to do it and as Bobby once
said to me we expect you to do miracles
but the miracle is not the people on the
set and I don't need to kiss up to you
anymore so that I'm not doing it for
that reason
but that they created 26 different
episodes a year out of a whole cloth out
of the thin air that is amazing that is
amazing that they could come up with as
creative as scripts as they did
continually and never to my mind
rehashed
anything really with all due respect to
the shows that father Desai sometimes
would turn to my wife when watching one
of the other shows and say I think I did
this episode completely the other thing
you guys did as a show was you had these
storylines that would run through the
season you know the the Dominion War the
list goes on and on and and I you know
in the doc it talks about how you know
studio resistance it's amazing
what you all did way ahead of the curve
and I think it's one of the reasons why
it stands up in the era of binge that
when people come in because you were you
know many years ahead of the curve so
can you talk a little bit about coming
up with those overarching storylines and
the resistance maybe you got from
executives it got easier to do because
at some point I told the writers you
know forget it we're not writing the
show anymore for the fans we're writing
the show for ourselves you know we seem
so lost in in the the the mix of other
Trek series and the movies and we were
so marginalized or at least we felt
marginalized and we made that into a
strength
that's how I I looked at it it's like no
one's watching anymore not as closely so
let's do what we want and you know Mike
and Rick they created the show I had
nothing to do with that they created the
show and that pilot there were just so
many elements of that pilot that were
ripe to run with and I felt like I'm
going all the way with all of them I'm
you know we're gonna make this you know
we're gonna make this show different the
pilot was different the show's gonna be
different and sometimes I there was
support and sometimes there was a lot of
pushback and you know someone asked me
earlier in the day if I was ever
concerned that I was going to get fired
for all the arguing that went on during
the show and it never even crossed my
mind back then you know if some
would have wanted to fire me nothing
would have changed you know to let him
fire me at this point I knew what my
mandate was and you know I I needed to
enjoy the show
I wanted the cast as much as the cast
was able to enjoy the show there was
nothing much enjoyable about being on
that said all the time in that makeup
and so that was that was the deal it was
easy to go see realize because we were
doing it for ourselves I I don't know I
don't remember what the ratings were
back then but how was it each year
scared shitless about getting renewed or
did you feel like it was when you know
what I mean like and how was it through
the whole show I remember having this
debate with Renee all the time Renee
came from series TV and and he was
concerned about ratings but we
understand we were the second in an
experiment about syndication so ratings
wasn't all that important at least to me
maybe it was to you maybe was to the
rest of you but not to me and I remember
having a constant argument with Renee he
him always saying a wonderful get picked
up I said we'll go for seven years
I said TNG went for seven years we'll go
for seven years that's the number that's
that's the magic number for syndication
so I don't think I can only speak for
myself I it never occurred to me that I
wouldn't have seven years work unless I
really did something ridiculously stupid
and they decided to kill me off which
they did in one episode so thanks to you
thank you very much but but that was and
in fact early on do you remember early
on I think was like the third or fourth
episode because our contract said they
could get rid of us after two or three
episodes do you remember this
conversation it's about the time that I
said about the 20 years as well because
we were thinking we have to do well or
they'll get right it could get rid of us
because our contract said they had a
choice up for about two or three
episodes whether we were going to stay
or not I I worried about getting fired I
mean I thought about it but I kind of
know why would you I thought I thought I
always thought I was gonna get fired
because I was always pushing the
envelope so and I knew that there were
people who
found her too much but I felt like IRA I
felt like he was a role that for a woman
it was like the cage door had been left
open and I could either walk carefully
out or I could run run out of the cage
and that's what I felt like I did I was
gonna run and if they you know she shot
me down so be it but I'm gonna run I'm
gonna make a run for it that's that's
how I felt but I I knew there was risk
no I came in like you know you know Andy
the Andy the actor with his lunch pail I
had no expectations I got hired for an
episode now you know I assume that the
cheque was gonna clear the bank you know
and and I did my episode and I walked
away thinking I would never see this
thing again and then they kept on
calling me back and calling me back and
and and and then it was the oddest
experience of my professional life I've
never had one ottar where I job started
with such low expectations and
especially I was up for odo I didn't get
odo so when they call me back to do an
episode I didn't want to do it I didn't
want to come to the audition Irene said
you've got to pay the bills going to the
audition got the job did it had a very
nice time and then this thing grew to
something we're not what what year are
we in 2019 here we are we're still
talking about this mother
when did you realize your character
became a fan favorite I never knew my
character was a fan favorite honestly
but I did know that my character was a
writer's favorite that's when I knew I
was onto something and it was it was an
episode in the second season called The
Wire that I realized that when I got the
script and the writing was by it was by
a guy me Robert wolf right yeah and and
the writing was wonderful and again and
he was these areas and these demented
insane drug you know addled areas that
that the character was doing that I
realized oh my god they they they liked
this character I think I'm gonna be
around for a while for you guys
who took home what from set and why ha I
got nothing
Rene Auberjonois got everything it was
like the Visigoths sacking Rome for
Christ's sakes I will say and I will say
no more is in that last week Joe Longo
who was the property master on Deep
Space nine gave me the beckoning finger
and walked me into his property Shack
and said whatever you want and
unfortunately I was since learned better
but at the time I was very selective but
there are things I have or I might have
because I don't know what the statute of
limitations is on this but I have some
things that that have meaning to me I
mean I have this gentleman's head and I
have an auto mask that are prominently
displayed the first thing you see
walking into my house is his face is the
is the right there in the entranceway
glass case is is a quark head I wish I'd
been nicer to Joe I know I know what's
painful is that they said do not take
anything do not take anything from this
set but you saw them just ripping it
down and throwing it away and you know
and just taking it away I guess they
weren't throwing it away they were they
were cataloging it for iris even Baran
for Renee this is what I'm thinking now
I wish I could have kept some of the set
pieces I you know there are things that
I would love to have that's what I want
that sort of Kayla Kayla no we don't
talk about that take home anything you
like I did not take anything home not
that I didn't want to but the NAS right
that we were told not to but but more
importantly really important I I
mentioned before about stepping onto the
set for the first time in that memory
still is with me 25 plus years later and
I did not want to tarnish that memory I
did not want to see that incredible
creation in disrepair luckily for me
Doug Drexler who was one of the scenic
designers when he heard that I had
nothing from the show very kindly gave
me a artifact from quarks bar which
hangs in my office but I personally did
not and I'm grateful enormous ly
grateful I never saw the promenade in
disrepair I never have to live with that
memory the show is now on Netflix when
has it has have you noticed when it
started streaming that all of a sudden a
ton more people have now watched it and
you know their reaction to it I knew the
moment it I didn't know the moment it
started streaming but the moment it
started streaming I was at a convention
and a 15 year old boy came up to me and
said oh my gosh I've got such a crush on
major Kira and I was like what this is
this is a whole different generation
this is weird
and it started this way than I realized
it was because it was streaming and
people could see it the way it's best
meant to be seen
you know binge watching it where you can
really see the arcs and what the writers
were doing so brilliantly also the
convention is when I first ran into a
young girl whose parents and
grandparents were fans and you know
what's weird
I am man brought his daughter named Kyra
and he also brought a picture of himself
in my arms when he was little
right I'm all what yep but that's yeah
it's mind-blowing it's really cool when
one of the things about the doc has it
has some footage in HD and what I've
heard that it's a real challenge to get
Deep Space nine remastered in some sort
of HD do you know is it possible is it
something that's being pursued or is it
sort of stuck in this weird time and era
from when the production was made well
we can say it's definitely possible we
remastered about 22 minutes for the film
and it's a very time intensive and
expensive process and because of the
time and expense it took CBS to do the
next generation you know Deep Space nine
has kind of always been not not as
possible as that they a lot of the
effects were done in CGI they would have
to be completely redone so it's an it's
an additional cost from what they've
gone through on the past and I think
it's it's an expense that they are not
yet ready to make the leap for the whole
series but I think when people start
seeing the footage and see how how it
modernizes Deep Space 9 how it brings it
to I mean you could be watching
something that is airing on TV nowadays
that we talked about the sets before I
mean seeing the stuff the the low
lighting but very dramatic and specific
lighting they were using which was
different frankly very different at the
time I think then you know TNG or
Voyager or one of the other shows on on
a brightly lit ship I think when people
see that they they are gonna change
their minds and hopefully you know the
powers that be will will consider that
and we'll we'll take a look again at a
moment that will stand out in my mind
from the many years we would working on
this dock was walking into the post
house and seeing Jonathan West who's the
DP the ds9 DP for the last five seasons
and they would do in color correction on
the HD and he was looking up at a
monitor I don't remember it was actually
one of these two guys it was either I
don't know if it was Andy or
yeah it was it was Andy or it was Armand
I can't remember now who it was and he
was literally looking like this he was
like a little kid in a candy store he
was so happy and what he said his exact
words were I always knew it could look
like this I always know when we were
filling it I knew how good it would look
and we never achieved that you know they
never did that on the on the DVDs but
finally I'm seeing what this show could
look like and he was so happy with such
a beautiful moment and you know the HD
is definitely an eye-opener that being
said it's easy to spend other people's
money and you know I don't have to you
know I'm not I'm not responsible to CBS
Digital or CBS anything and I'm there's
definitely people within that
organization who would love love love to
see it remastered the whole thing there
we have a lot of people in our corner
but of course they don't control the
purse strings you know I want the
creative ones I I wonder if something if
there's a way and this is me spitballing
but I wonder if the streaming numbers on
Netflix or these other companies you
know what I mean I wonder if there's a
way of getting a streaming exclusive on
one of the one of the things whether it
be Netflix whether it be Hulu or Amazon
and then helping to contribute to the
remastering costs to have the exclusive
rights wouldn't you need a spokesman to
be or a group of people to say we want
this I don't think paramount the true
Ferengi could could or CBS would do this
on their own you need someone with some
vision to be able to say we should do
this and look at the streaming numbers
yes and this is not gonna cost you as
much as you think it's gonna cost you
thank you yeah well that's the reason
why I'm saying if one of the streaming
companies wanted to take own you know
what I mean but I don't know what the
contracts are and but listen everyone's
looking for content and reasons to you
know to tune it and I'm curious so there
were 26 episodes in a season how often
did the storyline of the entire season
how often did it
I would imagine day one you guys are
figuring out the arc or you know
figuring out where it's all gonna go how
often did it change along the way in any
sort of dramatic ways and for the actors
I'm curious if there was a lot of
collaboration with any of the writers or
if it was always here's the script it
was pretty much always here's the script
but you know for me I mean because of
the writing I only one time did I ever
you know question things and that was a
scene with Arman and and it was our
man's fault he was the instigator yes
yes I was an instigator we'll talk about
that later well I I have a question well
we can also open that door but but
please go on I had a part two for you
the I agree with Andy we you know the
the the best words or letters that we
could hear on the set was from Judy
Brown our script coordinator who when we
finished a scene or or a sequence of
scenes are shot we would all turn to
Judy and wait for these words and that
she said dlp lovey then we knew we could
move on dlp means dead letter-perfect
that means we had said it exactly the
way the writers wanted us to say it
because if we didn't do it that way for
the most part it meant another take oh
I'll say is this every season I would
come in
you know the writers only had two weeks
off a year towards the end last three
seasons they rebelled and I gave them
three weeks off but but so I would come
in I would know kind of in the broadest
way possible the shape of the series the
shape of the season but I always assumed
that I always tell them that I expect
everything to change by midseason course
we're better you know the season will
just get better in the season will tell
us what it has to be if I knew the exact
end of a season at the beginning of the
season then I would feel we're not doing
our jobs that the show is kind of
moribund
and and isn't teaching us anything they
agree the people in the other room we're
watching and they agree but certainly
characters like Garrick and and Adam are
when those actors and those characters
came in on to scene I'm sure you didn't
know where they were gonna go when you
created them well absolutely damar as we
say in the doc he had two lines you know
I just happened to know Casey from other
things and I knew he was a good actor
and i said i wa and plus we needed
someone
we were so Cardassian dependent on Mark
Alaimo and I wanted to give him someone
to play off of who was Cardassian as
opposed to you know he had Jeff but that
wasn't really you know enough so that
just worked at Garrick you know I always
say Garrick is the only character and
obviously yes with the wire and other
things he deepened there's no doubt
about that but Garrick kind of came out
of peat fields fully formed in that we
knew that he was a man we were never
gonna know you know that he was know
that would but that that we knew with
that with that character he was the
closest of someone who kind of was
nailed almost immediately from our point
of view he was a perfect starting our
point of the recurring characters others
it took some time to to see exactly what
they can do and how much we needed them
but but Garrick definitely was an
exception one of the things I found
fascinating in the doc was learning that
you would have people over on the
weekends to rehearse and go over things
and I wanted to know when did that first
get started and it's so unusual talk a
little bit about what would happen at
that those rehearsals that did happen
and it's a great tribute to the other
actors Andy Renee max even Wally Shawn
would give up their weekends to come
over to my house I think they just came
to visit my wife basically but they
would give up their weekends or at least
one day of the weekend to come to my
house to rehearse law
talk about specifics to discuss what the
arc of the scene was what were the
intentions of the scene and most actors
would grumble at the fact that they're
being asked to rehearse without being
paid none of these people ever did that
and there's a great credit to them it
was a spirit of the show that all of the
actors and the writers created of
wanting to do the very best work
possible and out of that spirit of
wanting to do the very best work
possible they gave up days of their
weekends many times dozens of times to
come to the house and rehearse it's it
it'll it has a little bit to do with
what in an asset by we we would normally
have anywhere from 10 to 16 hour days
those of us a make up had longer not
that you didn't wear makeup you had that
little thing which is another story that
little thing that's I'll tell you about
that later and but we we realized that
come 11th hour twelfth hour brain dead
we were brain dead the living inside as
you said living inside the makeup was
stall defying and and and difficult and
so we needed to rehearse because we
never knew what was going to be the last
thing shot so we needed to have that
rehearsal to depend on when we couldn't
think anymore that we like doing a play
in our body we have it in our bodies and
you mentioned and we were talking off
camera but did any of that rehearsal
impact dialogue onset or impact certain
scenes in a way that you know you didn't
expect and II referred to one episode
which IRA was a part of is it's at least
one of my favorite stories I think it's
one of Andy's as well after one of those
rehearsals at my house where Andy and I
came to realize a relatively comic scene
had a great deal of depth to it and
innuendo and subtlety
and we came to realize that here were
the two Machiavelli's on the ship having
a discussion about Starfleet comic
machiavel and the serious Machiavelli
and we began to realize that we were
talking in code we thought the
characters were talking in code and we
came to the set Monday or Tuesday
whatever day it was and presented this
approach to the directors and Jim Conway
and he said this is a comic scene you
can't play it that way and it's the only
time that I put my foot down and he
helped as well and said we'd really like
to play it the way we want to play it we
see more depth to this then then perhaps
you are seeing it and I'm sure mr.
Conway was taking his marching orders
from the writer directors the right of
producers and and he very smartly and
wisely sagaciously said I have to leave
this up to IRA so I believe you and
Robert Hewitt wolf came down to the set
to see what this disagreement wasn't for
them to come to the set as IRA said they
were busy they made time to come out and
take a look and Ira asked us to show us
what we had decided he said can you do
it the way Jim wants you to do it I
think we made a half-hearted attempt at
that Andy and in a matter of seconds
truly I don't think it was more than 10
or 15 seconds I returned to the director
and said shoot it that way yeah I mean
this is one of those stories that that
you know I find fascinating because
obviously it had a tremendous meaningful
impact - definitely - Armand because
we've spoken about it over the years and
and Andy as well and to me it was you
know they had to remind me of it number
one I hadn't even remembered the
incident and when they mentioned it I
recalled it Andy and Armand who it was
such a no-brainer and I and I pretty
much know what Jim was dealing with
because I would have the meetings with
the directors the tone meetings
a lot of the times I would talk about
the scenes with the Ferengi and I would
try to get this character humor out of
them and a lot of the directors had not
a lot of comic experience we didn't have
with the exception of Renee I'm hard
pressed to think of a director who had a
lot of comedy chops in his resume which
was always frustrating to me so I always
gave that speech and I think Jim took it
extremely seriously because he he wanted
it you know it wasn't about the words
the words were the same it was all about
intent and intention right and so when I
saw the difference I mean it was night
and day I mean it wasn't you know
there's still a lot of humor in the
scene it's just very subtle and and and
but it was just like you know the same
thing with with Nanaia and I will talk
to me about something that happened that
she felt was like such a big to-do you
know that you know I was called to the
set to talk to her about it and it seems
so minor compared to like the fights I
was having with other people you know
not actors paramount yeah so it just
seemed like we'll just straighten it out
and it'll all be fine but well because
we were all on the same side fighting
for the same thing we just we just
wanted it as truthful and good as it
could possibly be which is what you
always want it to so it was a
collaborative they were collaborative
arguments I always felt like they were
collaborative arguments with you
yeah except you did say you know here's
something you're not asking but this is
my bitterness is about it come this is
here comes the bitterness what was I
should have said this other people asked
this and I forgot what's the most
surprising thing that came out of this
documentary
what what blew my mind the one thing
that blew my mind more than any other it
was during a discussion we had back in
15 right in Vegas when we had all the
the
the main cast I was interviewing them
all at once and this woman over here
said well you know when I retain down
into the set it was like another suit
coming down to the set it's an awful
phrase and she meant it I did and it was
like I literally I thought I'm a suit I
was a suit I I thought we were all on
the same we were all the team together
whether we always agreed or didn't that
didn't mean that no but that suit didn't
mean you were on the other side to me
but it it meant a certain kind of
authority for sure for sure but it was a
creative authority figure I would hope
but that's not a suit I know you know I
know it's just words but you know words
are oh I I got to tell you something I
see both sides of this you were the boss
and ultimately we're making big
decisions but at the same time you were
so invested in the characters in the
show that you felt like you were one of
the team absolutely I totally get it I'm
bait listen I have like 79 more
questions and I'm effed so because I'm
already being given the wrap-up signal
but I have to ask you one other thing
real quick I love the series finale and
I'm curious when did that get figured
out and for each of you talk a little
bit about what your thoughts on the
series finale and what it meant to you
when when was it figured out IRA do you
want to deal with that well I'm not sure
what what you mean in terms of what this
story was of like how you figure big it
doesn't a series finale for a show like
this it means a lot because we've been
so invested for seven years you curious
what's gonna happen to Sisko and the
prophecy and all that stuff so I'm just
curious when it all came together for
you guys well you know those last 10
episodes we were so jazzed you know we
we got talked about a second wind so we
were all like we weren't thinking so
much about this is the end and the
finish line and we're tired and we care
it was like wow this is this is great so
breaking the story was was just another
story that had to be broken and we
gave it its Duggal was a two-hour
important ending and I want I knew that
was not gonna be a feature and I wanted
everyone to get you know an ending of
some sort the thing that drove me crazy
was what was the last shot where do we
and for all year I kept saying it's
we're ending we have to end in Quark's
bar with quark he's the bartender he's
the last you know it's he's he's the
continuation no matter whether we're on
the air or not quark is at that bar and
all through the season that's what I
said but as we got to the ending that
was I was driving myself crazy I said is
that is that because the thing with
Cisco and and and not having the captain
around and III was going nuts and my
wife said I'm taking you up to Santa
Barbara for the weekend and you're gonna
relax and stop thinking about this
goddamned show and you'll figure it out
I said I don't know and so we spent the
weekend up in Santa Barbara nothing came
to me and I was driving home I was on
the 101 on the PCH driving back from
Santa Barbara and boom right there as
I'm looking at the the windshield
I see Kira and and Jake standing out
looking at the window it's all about
family it's about the Sun looking for
his father you know it's about the the
son alone but not alone because it's
still the family at Deep Space nine and
it was like and I said honey I just
figured the ending and she said well it
took you long enough it took yeah yeah
you you are here all weekend so that was
that was an amazing final yep
the last episode is a tearjerker because
it's the end of a wonderful glorious
time but but if I have to pinpoint one
thing that because there were so many
flashbacks of things that had happened
in previous episodes for me the most
memorable and the most moving part of it
was watching
Ciroc grow up in the flashbacks because
I was right it was a family at times
dysfunctional absolutely but but tell me
whose isn't
yes exactly whose isn't but in in each
of our small ways and Avery did more
than all of us put together but each of
our small ways we all helped bring
Soraka and to watch him mature from that
young boy that started in the first
episode to that giant of a man at the
end it's not just the physical change
it was the maturity and to this day I am
in awe of Sirach Lofton and but to watch
him grow up on camera that to me was
takes that takes my breath away for me I
mean it was I was the happiest time you
know I'd never been happier in terms
your working situation that last season
and and and because of the storyline
which I was blown away about and the
transformation of the character of
Garrick you know really and and the
space that I found at the end and
there's a playing space you know there's
a psychic space that when good writing
you know
connects and with wood at the right time
and and and you're able to expand
yourself as a performer as an actor and
it was throughout the entire series
there was that space that constantly was
growing was growing that was growing for
me which is one of the great things
about doing a piece for seven years but
that last storyline which just I I
sailed with that I just opened my wings
and just flew I wept for two weeks I
couldn't stop crying
I even messed up shots because I just
burst into tears it was really really
hard it was like being from a village
you know from the time you're born it
felt like and then being told you have
to leave now just start walking don't
know where you're gonna live but this
isn't your home
anymore it felt like being turned out it
was so hard I again have about eighty
nine hundred other questions but you
guys have to go do other things I'm just
gonna say sincerely again how much I
loved the show and how happy I am you
guys all came in and I recommend the doc
to everyone it's if you've never seen
the show but especially if you've seen
the show thank you so much thank you
Steve
yes actually because there's such
surprising things he even us when we saw
the documentary for the first time we
were gobsmacked at what we didn't know
completely